first of all thank you very much for
inviting me to give a talk in this
conference welcome to St Louis I
actually live in St Louis and I'm going
to talk about the veracy ruin
Observatory the Legacy survey of space
and time I'm currently affiliated with
the Department of astrophysical Sciences
of Princeton University but you know
that we're going to help I'll start
worker for the slack National
accelerator laboratory which is a
department of energy laboratory managed
by Stanford University
and that's also part of of this project
um so in this talk I'm gonna give her a
big brief overview of the four
components of the Rubin Observatory
which is the telescope inside the camera
that we built the data management system
and the location of poly cartridge
systems and I'm going to mention the
science themes behind this galaxy survey
that we want to do in particular I'm
going to focus on cosmology which is
what I do observational cosmology
and we're going to talk a little bit
about the who Vera Roofing was and
darmaric dark energy and stuff like that
so I wanted to start with the mission
and statement of the Rubin Observatory
so the mission of this Observatory is to
build
a well understood system that will
produce an unprecedented astronomical
data set for the studies of the deep and
dynamic universe
made the data widely accessible to a
diverse community of scientists and
engage the public to explore the
universe with us and I wanted to read
this because there's a lot to unpack
there it's telling us that we haven't
done this before it's an impression
system at this scale
and we want to do a studies of what we
call the Deep Universe we want to do
cosmology you want to integrate a look
at very very flame galaxies at the same
time we want to do what we call a
dynamic Universe which is all the stuff
that changes on the sky on different
time scale so this is these two things
are gonna be at odds and it's gonna be
challenging to put together the the
technical requirements for to to make
the scientific goals
in addition to this we want to involve
all the astronomical community in in the
United States and in Chile and in the
world the Chile is where the telescope
is going to be and a very important
point of this is that since the
beginning of the project the education
and public outrage component was there
from the beginning was usually in
astronomy EPO is important everybody
loves astronomy but then you don't give
money to it and then then yeah that's it
enough then it's an afterthought so the
the Rubin Observatory is going to
conduct a survey a Galaxy survey that is
called a legacy survey of space and time
it's going to last for 10 years and if
we put it in one sentence given by one
of the
intellectual
architects of this project sanitizen we
can say we can put an optical camera of
about on a on an eight meter telescope
with a field of view of the size of 40
full moons and then we're gonna use this
camera to take 1 000 photographs of
every area of the visible sky for 10
years so you can more or less picture
that next time you look at the full moon
you're gonna think of the
large field of view that this camera is
going going to have and I said this is
something unprecedented
the lssd
the Legacy survey of space and time is
going to be the first project of the
Rubin Observatory and it's going to give
us the next step in in astronomy so here
I'm putting pictures of space telescopes
this is another ruin Observatory you
might recognize the jwst during my break
and then there are other telescopes
called the Euclid the Space Telescope
and the NASA
Nancy Grace Roman Space Telescope on the
right and these are telescopes that are
going to complement what the Rubin
Observatory is going to but the real
power of a telescope is given by the
power of the about the product of the
field of view and the size of the mirror
that it has so in terms of that number
that is called at ndu or grasp the Rubin
Observatory is actually the best of all
and he's going to give us a catalog of
about 20 million stars and 20 billion 20
billion galaxies with an excellent
catalog of properties positions and and
brightness so basically we can say that
we're going to have a digital and color
movie of the universe
um so just for historical purposes many
some of you may know may not but this
project was called the larcenoptic
survey telescope in the past for
historical reasons but
then the National Science Foundation
who's providing part of the funding of
this project decided to call name it in
in honor of veracy ruin uh due to the
Herrick in recognition of her
contributions to the study of that
matter and her advocacy for the equal
treatment and representation of women in
science
so just to be a little bit more
specifics
uh the lsst
um the the objectives of the lsst are to
obtain a catalog of millions of images
five we're going to take about six
millions images with about 200 detectors
I'm gonna explain a little bit more
about these detectors later we're going
to calibrate these images which is
actually what I work on something called
instrument signature removal a little
bit technical but it's basically
cleaning all the images from
whatever the detector is giving you and
it's not the signal then we need to
produce the catalogs of the detected
objects and then we also need to make
that amount of data available to the
users which as I said is the scientific
community
not only astronomers other people with
Technical expertises and also the the
General Public
so the ultimate deliverable of the lsse
is not just building this telescope but
it's also the fully reduced science
ready data and the software as well
which is all open science from the
historical point of view this idea came
back in the 2000 it was initially called
a dark matter telescope and in 2010 it
was recognized by the National Academy
of Sciences as the most important
ground-based astronomy
um project that the United States should
focus on so every 10 years in the United
States the astronomical Community gets
together and decide whether they're
going to spend the money on and then
they produce a report with the National
Academy of Sciences
that is read by Congress by NASA by
people who have money and then they say
okay this is the product that we should
build
we're going to build this telescope in
the northern part of Chile or more or
less the center Chile is very long it's
called cero pachon uh there are
different reasons why we chose to build
an optical telescope there the most
important one is clear and is semi
desertic is you when you want to build
an optical telescope you want a place
where is not humid
and there are also other political
reasons and also they also they already
have the the land there to to build
other telescopes this is just a picture
of the site
and a picture of the one of the
astrophotography of the type of Skies
that you can get from there
so without the first component of this
project is the telescope and site this
is a subsystem that of course includes
the telescope itself the buildings and
facilities and everything that you need
in order to support the operations of
this roaming Observatory
so on the right hand side you see inside
that funky looking building and there
you see we have all sorts of technical
equipment here this is usually you don't
have that type of facilities in an
astronomical Observatory
an interesting
um picture that you see on the lower
left is actually the tunnel that goes to
the mountain he has a certain width so
the maximum diameter of the telescope
was also constrained by what you can fit
in in that tunnel so that was about 8.4
meters so of course you want to build a
bigger telescope but at the same time
you have these types of practical
constraints
these are more pictures of the telescope
Mount assembly and then some pictures
from the top of the telescope that also
already
finalized Construction
then the next thing I wanted to talk
about is the camera so this is a very
cool camera is called the elasticity
camera
a very original names that we have in
astronomy and is the largest digital
camera ever built so that's really
amazing so it has a Dimensions about a
meter and a half by three meters and it
weighs about what a car weights so here
we have it in the imperial system units
and just to make a comparison one funny
order of magnitude or Fermi problem that
a colleague of mine did is how many
corgis I could fit in the camera
and I was like oh all right I don't know
what assumptions it's spherical corgis
you know in physics we call it spherical
cause so I guess she did the calculation
and
and she said that she didn't harm any
corgis
um well the so here this is a picture of
where the camera was built which is that
a slack National accelerator laboratory
in California
like as I said is the highest resolution
digital camera in the world and they
actually got a Guinness World Record to
prove it so yeah and somebody did the
calculation and said you would be able
to spot a golf ball on the moon while
standing on Earth to give you an idea of
the type of resolution that you have
with this camera
um as I said is the largest digital
camera ever built for astronomy and also
it has the fastest data readout time of
any camera build so far because we need
to in order to to attain one of those
scientific objectives of looking at
everything that changes in the sky you
need to actually read the camera very
fast and then go to the next part of the
sky and so on and so forth in order to
do cosmology you need to look at the
very very faint fainter galaxies of the
universe so you need to look at things
for 10 years
so that's why we call Deep white and and
fast this is a schematic of of the
camera on the left the the lens the
first lens I believe is also the largest
lens in in the world or something like
that
um
and this is let's see if this goes yeah
it's it's moving so this is a schematic
of the type of of filters that you put
in in front of of the camera
so what's happening here is that when
astronomy is an observational science
you cannot go to a lab and just play
with your galaxies so that'll be cool so
what you look at
is the images of the galaxies and in a
great Perfect World Language we had all
the resources in the world we would
split the light of every Galaxy that we
get
and we do a spectroscopy right so for
every wavelength then you get a certain
amount of power
and then that tells you about the
chemical composition of the Galaxy it
tells you about the distance of the
Galaxy from from a city of the rotation
velocities of the Stars but uh that if
we did that for the billions of galaxies
that we wanted to then we would never
finish and we would need a lot of money
so we do something what is called
photometry this is the type of uh
information that a Galaxy survey like
this actually gathers which is just
basically taking pictures of
objects of celestial objects in
different filters and you can still see
by the difference in the in how they
look like in different wavelengths you
can still infer all these properties
that I told you in particular for
cosmology the distance is is very
important
so that's a little bit of the
explanation of the type of photometrical
survey that we're doing this is again
another picture in the slack
National accelerator laboratory and this
is a picture of the primary and tertiary
mirror in the
in Arizona in the University of Arizona
I forget the name of the lab Richard or
something but did you can see in the
center one of the the higher apps I
guess when you're a higher app you get
to Center on the on the on the expensive
mirror
um
one of them is Tony Tyson that I have
mentioned that came out with the idea
many many years ago and then you also
see that they're all men that's and also
another problem in astronomy that we
need to talk about and that's something
that Vera ruined also was very aware of
and asked us to to do better
this is
um actual pictures of the detectors so I
do I do a lot of work with something
that is called gravitational lensing
that I'm going to tell you more about
that and then I studied the the detector
sang how these detectors the errors when
these detectors are going to propagate
into the signal that I want to measure
these detectors are called charge couple
devices they're digital detectors and
they revolutionized astronomy so in back
in the time when they invented the
photographic planes that plates that
revolutionized astronomy of course then
in the 60s people invented the digital
detectors called the charge couple
devices
they were perfected in the 70s at the
jet proposal laboratory in in California
and then people started to build these
large cameras in the 90s and in the past
two two decades this large wide field of
view CCD cameras so here we're gonna
have 21 wraps or electric Towers you can
I call them sometimes each one of them
has nine detectors so we're gonna have a
total of 189 detectors to make this big
field of view that I talked about
these are more detailed pictures of the
camera at the slack already assembled we
haven't shipped the camera to to Chile
just yet but we're planning to do so
next year
these are again more pretty pictures of
the actual electronic graphs coming into
the focal plane
and then one more and more picture of
the of the guide sensors you on the on
this on the corners you have sensors out
of the plane to to do guiding and
alignment
when they finish the camera they did a
press release at the slack and then they
put a picture of of Vera ruin with a
pinhole camera now with the with the
actual lenses
and the lsst camera as I said is the
largest digital camera in the world that
we have built so far and is the
culmination of certain other types of
cameras that we have built in the past
decades the one you see at the in the in
the top left is called the hyper Supreme
camera that is in Hawaii that it has
also a lot of CCS but it doesn't have as
many as the one of the elasticity camera
and the one on the right I also wanted
to talk about because I did my PhD in
this project which is called the dark
energy survey that it has about 500
million pixels camera still it gives us
an idea this records a service of what
to expect with the lsst so I wanted to
show this animation of actual data and
this is from the Dark Energy camera this
is a telescope close to where the ruin
Observatory is being built
and you can see the the size of the Moon
you always kind of compare with the size
of the Moon in
the dark energy camera you can put about
like three full moons across that you
compare with that with the more or less
seven full Moves In in diameter that you
can put in the LLC camera but when you
do this type of
um Galaxy service this is how you do it
by tiling the sky little by little and
then coming back to it and doing it in
different filters and then with the dark
energy survey we only had money to a
little part of the sky it's not little
this is actually big this is like it's
five five thousand square degrees to the
18
000 Square degrees that we're gonna see
from Chile then we're gonna we're
talking about something different but we
already have this precursor projects
that are gonna tell us a little bit
about what what to expect
um then we have the data management
system I I so far I have worked for the
data management system and as I said the
software is one of the most challenging
aspects of the Roman Observatory
we're going to produce about 20
terabytes of data and that should be us
per night and that should be expressed
processed and stored each night so you
take all this data in in Chile close to
a town called La Serena so the the
telescope is about 50 kilometers or
something up the mountain and you send
the data to La Serena then he goes to
Brazil and then he goes to he used to
come here to Illinois the national
Center of super computer and
applications but now he's going to go to
slack and we also have Partners in
France and the United Kingdom so the
data also is going to go there
and I wanted to show this image this is
an image of what we call the
commissioning camera it has the type of
the same type of sensors that we have in
the lssd camera
it has this is like a one draft you see
the 9C series and each CCD has 16
segments because you want to read the
charts quickly so one way of doing that
is just to splitting the detector in in
many many areas but you can see a
picture of somebody in the lab and then
you can see all these horrible stuff on
top of it so that's the job of the
instrument signature removal pipeline to
get rid of that and then you see like
things like rings and
uh again I wrote up a bit of what those
rings are like all the electric field in
the CCD you have the photon producing
the charge with the photoelectric effect
and actually that's moving my charge
from one pixel to the other pixel so
that's bad because then I think that the
Galaxy was in Blunt place but it's
actually in another place and that's
also bad because I thought that the
Galaxy had this brightness but it has
another brightness so that's not good
for the science that we want to do and
here I'm saying it very colocally but
I'm talking about like one percent
effect on something very very tiny that
for a project like this is actually
going to be important because a project
like this wearing what we call the
systematic Limited regime
for the for all our lives and astronomy
we did not have objects users we could
only see a little part of the sky and
then we have like three galaxies and
from that we need to draw a line and say
this is cosmology this is the Milky Way
now the statistical problem is going to
be solved we're going to have billions
of galaxies and now we're gonna be in
the regime in which if we want to make
progress we need to pay attention to all
these systematic errors that do not go
down when you do an a statistical
average
um this is another slide just to make an
emphasis on that and saying that
existing tools and methods are not going
to scale up to what we want to do
and we have we're going to have this a
huge statistical data database about 100
petabytes for each of the 40 billion
objects they're gonna be about 1 000
measurements I said and then each one
with a few dozen parameters so then we
end up with a TENS of tens of thousand
dimensional parameter space so we have
the challenge of characterizing what we
know the north patterns we need to
classify the populations that we might
find
we need to discover the unusual objects
the unknown unknowns and this is one of
the most exciting aspects of of this
type of projects we're gonna we don't
know what we're gonna find
and it's going a lot of people put a lot
of effort in developing new techniques
that we haven't used in in previous
um in previous projects using techniques
from other fields like computer science
artificial using techniques from
artificial intelligence and machine
learning of course
and as I mentioned before one important
component of the ruin Observatory is
education and political Outreach we want
to do it in a systematic way in which
people can do what is called citizen
science or Community science in which
members
non-subject matter Experts of the
community can contribute
to to the scientific effort that that
we're going through and I I actually
when I moved to San Luis I didn't have a
job and I found an astronomer colleague
in Edwardsville Illinois and I had a
chance to work on this type of community
science projects from the scientific
point of view so it's something very
valuable and as I said it is very
important that the ruin observatories
from the beginning
putting a lot of emphasis on education
and public Outreach
for this other part of the talk I wanted
to mention the the four science drivers
of lsst these are the main drivers that
what what we want to do with it but as I
said we're going to be able to do much
more than this
so one of the science goals is cosmology
cosmology is the by definition is the
study of the universe as a whole we want
to learn about the composition of the
universe something called Dark Matter
and dark energy that I'm going to tell
you in detail later
uh but we also want to know about our
own solar system we're going to do
different
um
inventory of the different populations
of the solar system all those asteroids
that are between Mars and Jupiter or
all this stuff that is beyond Neptune
which are called trans-neptunian objects
uh all these things are actually
remnants from the early history of the
universe and we wanna make an inventory
of this uh objects and in addition we
have this population of objects called
near Earth objects and uh that by
definition they're close to the Earth
but a subset of them are what we call
potentially hazardous or objects or
asteroids well things that could kill us
basically so that's also an important
thing that we're gonna catalog with the
lsst actually in 2005 the Congress
mandated NASA to find 90 of the objects
that could actually
pose a threat to
to the Earth
that have that are more than
140 meters or kilometers well sorry for
the order of magnitude sleep in my mind
but the point is that there is a
threshold that even at that threshold is
going to be very dangerous for for us so
the elasticity is actually going to help
um fulfill this uh this mandate we also
want to know about the Milky Way the
structure formation our own Galaxy the
origin of our own Galaxy and we want to
explore as I said what we call the
transient Sky we have a lot of variable
Stars we have exploring Stars called
supernovae we have stuff called active
Galactic nuclei black holes or we're
going to discover new types of of
transients so we basically we've never
done that in the past you have these
different subsets of the astronomical
community and they build their own
project to do the each type of science
because it's really hard to actually do
a single project that is going to make
the whole astronomical Community happy
so I wanted to focus on on the cosmology
side a little bit and I wanted to talk
about first the weather ruins so Dr ruin
was born in in Philly born and raised
and in the 1928 she moved to DC
afterwards when she was 10 years old and
she went to Vassar College and then the
high school teacher told her oh you'll
be fine as long as you stay away from
The Sciences
and like of course and then but then
Ruben's like now what are you talking
about I she had a role model called
Maria Mitchell the first American
astronomer who got a PhD that she
thought advisor so ruin thought well of
course I can also be there an astronomer
why not so then she wanted to go to grad
school she got accepted to Harbor but
then she said she decided to follow her
her husband and then probably she was
happy to do so but at the same time you
have all these other pressures that you
can measure systematically that women
are more pressure to follow their
Partners than the other way around so
that could and that's something that's
that still happens so she ended up going
to Cornell which I guess is not bad she
wanted to go to Princeton
uh but they tell her like now you're a
woman so you cannot study here so then
she went to Georgetown to get her her
PhD
and I think she stayed afterwards about
10 years or also and then let me tell
you about
um why uh with the type of contributions
that she did for astronomy so back in
the time in the 30s there was this Swiss
guy called fritz swiki or his wikis
pardon my Swiss German and he was
working at Caltech and then he was
looking at clusters of galaxies
and the galaxies everything goes around
everything rotates in the universe so
the clusters of galaxies are orbiting
their Common Center of mass
um by applying physics to that you can
see how fast the the Galaxy clusters are
I'm sorry the galaxies are rotating in
the Galaxy cluster and you can infer the
amount of mass that must be causing that
movement and then he saw he did the
calculations that actually you would
need more mass that you can actually see
in order to explain those dynamical
movements and he called those uh that
missing Mass he call it dark matter
because it didn't absorb or emit
electromagnetic radiation
then Vera proven in the 70s I believe
look at different scales look at the
scales of galaxies and then she looked
at the velocity of the rotations of
galaxies around the center of the of the
of the Stars around the center of the
Galaxy
you would expect like in the solar
system that as you get further for
example in the solar system as you get
further from the Sun the planets the
orbital velocity of the planets goes
down and that's Newtonian mechanics
that's caplarian mechanics but they
actually did not find that they found
what we call the flattening of the
curves by using different type of
techniques you find out that the
velocity of the of the stars as a
function of the radius from the center
of the Galaxy did not diminish you can
explain these observations by invoking
the
hypothesis of a new type of model that
we don't know about that does not absorb
over meat electromagnetic radiation but
it has gravity so the current accepted
model of cosmology says that we have a
certain type of dark matter that is
called caulk colder matter
and every galaxy has a Halo of these
dark matter surrounding
um surrounding the the Galaxy the
picture on the right is actually an
actual picture of two clusters colliding
and by different techniques you can see
the gas of the galaxies going the shock
like when you have a bullet go through a
an Apple for example you can see the gas
in the center
and then on the right using another
technique that I'm going to talk about
you can know about the distribution of
that matter so you can actually see the
separation of the type of normal matter
and dark matter and the current part of
the Paradigm is telling us that galaxies
and classes of galaxies they all live in
what we call the cosmic web so this is a
simulation in which every bright point
is a Halo of dark matter they're joined
by filaments you have voice in between
and this the spatial scale of this type
of picture is about hundreds of millions
of of light years or Mega parsecs is the
unit that we use in astronomy but you
can think of it of hundreds of millions
of light years or you can think of like
oh this is very big because even a light
year you've I don't even remember in
terms of kilometers how it is but it's
the distance the light travels in one
year then we have some funny picture
from JPL about the dark matter and
for Halloween
but then I just told you that you cannot
see that matter by definition so how can
you see that matter so we can use a
technique called gravitational lensing
which is the basically
the bending of light by any distribution
of of matter or energy in the universe
this is an idea that comes from Alberta
Einstein from the theory of general
relativity of Albert Einstein from 1915
this is the best theory that we have to
understand gravity and that we're using
in cosmology and it tells us that if you
have something like the Sun or a Galaxy
and then you have a source in the
background and you're observing the
light from that source that light is
gonna get bent when it passes close to
to this Mass distribution so you can
it's called dancing because it is
analogous to the lensing of light for
example from a glass if you have a
candle and your source and you have a
glass of wine and then you can see the
effect of gravitational lensing which is
similar to what you actually observe in
galaxies you can see that you can form a
ring depending of the geometry between
the Observer the lens and the source you
can get a full ring which is called the
Einstein ring you can see multiple
images you can see a magnified image and
these are actual pictures of this
phenomenon from using the whole Space
Telescope so this is something that is
real that we can measure that blue arc
which is almost a ring is a Galaxy that
is way in the background and is being
lensed by a cluster or of galaxies that
is in in the foreground
these are pictures again of a cluster of
galaxies you need to squint a little bit
but the one on the left is from the
house Space Telescope the one on the
right is the one that recently they
showed to buy them in the when the jwst
had the first images
um and you can if you squint a little
bit you can see these arcs of galaxies
being lens and distorted in a tangential
way around the center of the cluster of
galaxies and this is a happy face using
from gravitational lens
so you know the human condition that we
want to see faces everywhere so it's
right here with gravitational lensing
again but then with gravitational
lensing we can know where dharmada is in
the universe so the name of the gain is
to get all these hundreds of millions of
galaxies at different types at different
distances the further you look back then
the more you're looking back in time
because the speed of light is is finite
so with that it's actually you can
reconstruct the history of the universe
by by looking at galaxies that are very
far away and then again you can make
this Cosmic weapon this this filamentary
web and know about the distribution of
galaxies and how it evolves in the in
the history of the universe
the current cosmological model and the
current theory is what is called a hot
Big Band Theory
plus inflation well there are some some
so so the Big Bang is there is not the
name of of a show now you say the actual
scientific theory that told us that
despite its name it was an explosion
it's it's always it's always on his
knowledge like impressionism and like
somebody wanted to make fun of big big
bands so they say ah Big Bang but it's
actually that in the past the universe
was very very hot very very dense
and it just started expanding and
cooling down so that's basically the
idea of the Big Bang cosmology
and that the evolution of the universe
is going to depend on the contents of
the universe as I said
the the best theory that we have to
understand cosmology is general theory
the general the theory of general
relativity that tells us that a
space-time is uh is curved by any
distribution of matter so the universe
is going to evolve depending of the
contents that of of what it has is not
going to be the same if we have a
universe that doesn't have any galaxies
that if it has more that matter
or more something else called dark
energy
so the universe started expanding and
this was to be this was already like a
big Discovery back in in the 1920s
actually Einstein himself after he wrote
the equations of general relativity he
showed that the Universe should be
spending but he didn't believe it he
actually put a mathematical term
to have a universe that should be static
because that was the belief of of the
time but then in the 20s it was observed
in in California among Wilson that the
galaxies actually are going farther and
farther away with with distance and this
provided
empirical evidence in favor of this idea
of a universe that is expanding another
empirical evidence is something called
The Cosmic microwave background which is
a signal that you can see all across the
sky is something that you can see on on
the right the picture on the right is a
projection of the sphere on the whole
sky and those difference in colors are
different in in temperature but these
differences are actually very very tiny
it's like one part in 1000 and this is
consistent with this leftover radiation
from from the big Bank
uh so they people were expecting that a
universe that is expanding and has
galaxies due to the gravity of galaxies
the universe should be slowing down it
came as a surprise in 1998 1998 when
people actually found out that the
universe is expanding faster and faster
with time so it's like if you have a
rock and then you throw it to the sky
and then it slows down and then out of
nowhere it starts speeding up so people
and scientists were thinking oh there
must be some sort of force or something
else that we don't know what it is that
is causing this
uh expansion accelerated expansion of
the universe so it's accelerated because
it's changing the velocity with time so
of course people very like what are you
talking about like this is not actually
this this cannot be what what it is but
then
um after uh this happened in 1998 in and
in the past 20 or 30 years
uh 25 then it has been actually
confirmed uh with other experiments that
the best hypothesis or the best model to
explain what we observe in the universe
includes a model that has dark matter
about 25 percent of of that matter every
of everything that's in the universe
there is 70 percent of everything that
is in the universe that is dark energy
and the rest like you and I and the
chairs and everything than the galaxies
and the Stars that's only five percent
so it sounds crazy but it is what the
model that explains the observations and
then we apply all kinds razor and that's
the model that we have and there's a
model that has been tested
and uh people with this type of galaxy
service people want to look at the data
which is the cosmic microwave background
and you can think of the cosmic
microwave of the baby universe and then
you apply your mathematical model your
cosmological model which is called
Lambda CDM Lambda stars for a type of
dark energy called dark matter
you apply that mathematical model and
then you forward it in time and then you
obtain
something that you should observe that
you can compare with what the
distribution of galaxies that you see
nowadays so you compare the baby
Universe with the adult universe and
then you see if your cosmological model
makes sense or not and this is by
starting the evolution of dark matter
through gravitational lensing and other
techniques throughout the history of the
universe
so this is one of the main motivations
for doing the the LSS team as I said and
I wanted to go a little bit more in in
detail of that because it's part of
mainly of what I'm doing of what I do in
my research
um this is just a rendering of the
current status of the ruin Observatory
it was supposed to be finished a couple
of years ago but because of the the
current pandemic then things had to stop
but we're making progress and maybe
let's see if we can look at the at a
video of the construction of the Roman
Observatory just for fun
so do you block the mountain my wife is
an ecologist and she was not happy about
that like it's like
then
you start building all this in in Chile
as I said one of the advantages is that
you already have the infrastructure to
bring all the materials and bring
everything
the land belong to something that is
called The Association of universities
for research in astronomy which is
something based in the United States so
they already have the land to to make
this this telescope they have an
agreement with the Chilean government
in which Chile is an equal partner in in
the project as well and then we have
already International Partners but Chile
is one of the main ones of course
and uh and he's getting there very
excited I might go there next year we'll
see because now we need to get things
going is what is called commissioning
there's gonna be a lot of of work
and I'm very excited and looking forward
to that
um yeah so I think it's uh
already seen but I'll finish it but I
want to finish with
um uh with the reminder of Vera Rubin
and what she stood for she's uh actually
she never got an oil price in physics
many people thought that she should have
gotten
should have gotten it but
naming the observatory after after here
is a way of honoring her Legacy and he's
not only about science but also honoring
the hardships that she went through and
how we need to do better so in
particular she experienced uh something
as a minority as a women but today we
know that many people of color many
minorities in astronomy here she was
talking to the Berkeley people who were
graduating and told them we only have
three black colleagues in with phds in
the United States you need to do better
uh so better ruin also stood for that
and how we need to do science in in a
better way and then we also need to to
take a think about those issues as well
and with that I'm gonna finish and you
can uh follow me on Twitter you can
follow my podcast in Spanish we want to
practice your Spanish listening skills
um thank you and I think I have time for
questions I guess technically but feel
free to email me or talk to me or I'm in
the slack message if you want more
details about anything
thank you very much
[Applause]